the word cilia actually comes from the
Latin word for eyelash which makes sense
as you can sometimes see them ringing a
cell as our eyelashes ring our eyes
cilia move organisms by beating In Waves
over their surface a psyllium which is
the singular of cilia has only two
possible positions during the effective
stroke the psyllium sticks out
perpendicular to the cell and during
recovery it folds back towards the
cell's surface in most ciliates the
Cilia are arranged in rows and the Cilia
of a road don't move all together at
once when some of the Cilia are in the
effective stroke others are in the
recovery stroke and in some ciliates you
can see the wave pattern this creates
and these waves are basically grabbing
onto the sticky viscous water yanking
the cell through